I got some news I want to talk about
regarding the Disney streaming service
and it shows there been some rumors and
rumblings about these shows for the
upcoming Disney streaming service app
this week first being the idea that
maybe the cancellation of Netflix is
Iron Fist our IP and Luke Cage bigger I
our IP means that the Heroes for Hire
show that we've been thinking about for
years is in the works though Luke a
Jennifers often both play a big part in
Heroes for Hire in the comics and that
would be cool it's really just a
conspiracy theory at this point we also
still have the Loki and Scarlet Witch
shows in the works and then lastly
there's been some talk about a potential
Nick Fury show and now people are saying
that that's not true but there is
something coming that is bigger and
better than a Nick Fury show that's the
rumblings online right now yes way cool
lasers I know it does look really good
but what are you guys thoughts on the
bigger and better show and what it could
be about what characters could we be
dealing with maybe teams could we
actually finally see the team that
freeform almost had was Squirrel Girl
remember that show they had it for a
second then it got canceled like now I
will find a place for it I never
happened on the pepper not power pack
not New Mutants it's the young young
young young the young uns the young
building up squirrely be like a Captain
Marvel asks you know rescuer there you
go and now that I love that show no she
is over on marvel rising the new
animated show playing Squirrel Girl so
good for her you made it there but no
yeah what kind of characters would you
want to see on this I think taking an
MCU proper characters and moving them
over
wouldn't it be confusing if they move
the Netflix characters over or does mi
think no no way the CW sold me over to
UPN and then Supergirl went from CBS
nice reference Supergirl and Constantine
they just like took him from enemies you
know like yeah that happened over here
yeah I'd love to see some version of a
damage control right that was exactly
what else in the works at first and then
they and then they did what they were
gonna do both there were two versions of
the same idea and I think neither happen
right what they did want on NBC they had
an actual show yeah like every revamping
and they they started with the same idea
of the ground controls maybe fill people
yeah I'll fill people in on what that is
so damage control it's it's a from the
Marvel Comics it's basically the
ground-level world it's almost like
agents of shield but more specifically
it's the people who have to clean up all
the messes every time like there's some
calamity like after the Battle of New
York or after sokovia or after the
Triskelion disaster like they're the
people who are like sweeping up and it's
almost like a kind of an office type
comedy but they deal with the aftermath
and rather than like the secret agent
world of agents of shield it's more of
like you know cleanup crew literally
good vultures story and because you have
damage control now but it would be fun
to get like a workplace comedy i watch
powerless it could've been better had
some good moments could've been better
but I got cancelled so yeah too late for
that shows a lot of interference on that
show yeah but I think if it's just like
complete Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
controlled version of this I think there
could be a really fun version of that on
the new Disney streaming app I'd love to
see that yeah damage control I'll doing
it as it is in the comics and keep in
that tone because it really is a great
comic series if we get any of the
Netflix characters they should do
daughters of the dragon before they
would do here's a Heroes for Hire mainly
because the fandom the Phantom behind
these shows that is vocal even though
we've seen like some statistics recently
they're like the word around Luke Cage
season 2 entire first season 2 was
pretty low that support behind some own
mystic as misty Knight and Colleen wing
Jessica hen wicks calling wing is its
way there also I think they're kind of
better actors all the way around so I
daughters of the Dragon series or even
Heroes for Hire and they're they're the
main characters of that show with Luke
and Danny being a part of it as well but
and I think I relegated to like side
characters on the show I mean I don't
know maybe it's maybe it's them for all
together but they're really good
characters and their strong actors and
they have support so Disney if you're
gonna pick some characters pick them a
little bone to pick with this whole
thing about Luke Cage and iron fist
apparently the word is they got canceled
because there wasn't enough social media
conversation not enough people were
tweeting about the shows that's how they
valued it to its success or not so it's
like social media and people that are
very vocal at dictating what we can and
can't be watching these days do you
think that's true that's what the report
said that there's just less online
traffic because that's the only thing we
can know but Netflix has their numbers
of how many people are watching don't
release their routines anyone about them
and they use it to their benefit but I
bet Netflix is kind of like if everyone
was watching it and it weren't being
talked about or not they probably would
have kept it mm-hmm but yeah I mean I
think that maybe that's the closest
thing we can use is social media because
it's true like when we would do videos
about it you guys remember we used to do
videos constantly about the the Netflix
universe Marvel Universe and then Iron
Fist came out and we kinda had to stop
because you guys didn't even want to
watch Wow videos about these things you
did yeah yeah I mean we cared enough to
make them right right it's like we
clearly were the people that cared but
they're just like it was a measurable
difference where he had to stop yeah
real quick let's get back into the idea
of what watch out I'm gonna throw one
out there and I want to hear somebody
taught me with a weirder one oh god I
would love for Hawkeye to finally get
his and he gets a show where he's
essentially Jason Bourne because that's
what they tried to do in the next Tom
Cruise even - if you're gonna do that
bring Kate Bishop on she's the other
hawkeye and I want to season she's my
favorite Hawkeye so and do its make it
spy stuff and or make it street-level if
you want to either way Hawkeye works
that works for both and have her either
he's training her or thinking he's
training her but she's already like
paste it she's already like a equal to
what is studio thank you look at me give
me something weirder a weirder showed
that Quicksilver but right before he
shot he runs around the world and like
lives his last is it makes I don't
really it makes sense but we could try
it Aaron taylor-johnson
you can do it I love that everybody else
would be in slow motion so he'd be like
living his last life but people
maybe runs back in time oh and then
comes back to get killed
yeah he's got to cuz time starts getting
all messer Doctor Who reference I don't
know yeah yeah one of you said earlier
in the Salonika one of you said a fan
owes origin story which I thought was
actually pretty cool
oh yeah something with his parents and a
large and/or just like essentially is
something out there instead of something
down here
yeah the cosmic story how about this you
take Nick Spencer great writer he's
writing spider-man right now he did a
superior foes of spider-man and it was
about the sinister six but was always
five people and they're all like the
lamest like like you know like it's part
of the it's part of the Oulu or like
everyone's like where's the sixth guy
like where are they and they're all
awful they're so incompetent and the
leaders always just lying he's always
lying even to you the reader it's it's
got some of my favorite moments in like
comics it will make it it'll tickle you
it'll make you mickey giggle it's a good
story and I think like incompetent bank
robbers is a fun concept that like
Marvel and then with Marvel you get fun
costumes too so maybe you can have some
fun there there was that deleted scene
from throw Ragnarok where Auden was
homeless right I wouldn't see how about
and where people think they can make him
fight another homeless person cruelly
I'll just one every go I'm gonna say no
it is yes if you wanted a kind of like
traveling with this like sadder hero
throughout like a wide like Silver
Surfer you go to different worlds and I
want something oh very cool that Bitcoin
I'm a to do but I just do the Fantastic
Four there yeah just stop trying to do
movies and just do the Fantastic Four
for people